what three things does a great story
have to have with three things hmm well
it has to be it has to have a hook that
gets people instantly involved in the
story and and that is a huge part of the
story itself and it's it's got to have a
very strong character in the story that
you care about and other than that it
has to have twists and turns that lead
to a surprise ending and like if I had
to just say three things I guess that's
what I would say the three things are
every every story needs that because a
story about nothing is not gonna hold
anyone's interest and and sometimes
writers when they begin their careers
think that they just if they just write
they can write about anything but the
truth is they need to write from their
heart about things that matter to
everyone and if they do that you can
hardly go wrong because stories are
really not about words or word choice or
anything like that they're about
conveying the power of a character
facing a dilemma that you have no idea
how he or she will will resolve and when
you do that you've got everyone's
attention and with in ancient times they
there was a thing called the oral
tradition which I used to teach as a
professor of Homeric Greek the Iliad and
the Odyssey were a sung you know at
campfires and everyone in the culture
knew the stories we're publishing a book
right now on Homeric song and how it
worked and how it held culture together
and my first book was about those I
called those stories the shield of
memory then it was because of those
stories that a person you had a deal
with himself in battle or when facing a
attacking boar or when facing an angry
wife you know or when facing the
pillagers trying to burn down his
village they he would instantly think of
the story of Heracles who did this and
that or the
you know agian who did this and that and
that's all they had they didn't have
books you know for learning it was all
passed along through the oral tradition
and I think stories have never failed to
play that role in human life when you
think about it you know what your story
is probably the most human response to
any encounter and it goes from the court
of law
where the jury is trying to decide which
of the two stories do they believe to a
political campaign where the voters are
making that decision to a first date
where you're going do I believe his
story I just don't believe it I can't
buy his story that's that's the ultimate
human turned out you can't buy the story
and it goes through everything
advertising is conveying stories that
people will you know so that people will
want to buy the product this is how
humans operate on a daily basis so to me
it's absolutely amazing that an industry
has been created where people will pay
millions of dollars for stories and
where stories can basically conquer the
world and I believe unites the world I
mean look at all the work we're doing
with China in the movie business I just
saw Lara Croft in Tomb Raider the new
version of it where the male lead is
Chinese and she is Western and clearly
as a producer I'm watching and going
this was a Chinese financed movie
because I understand how it works for
the market you know the Chinese hero
makes it perfect for the Chinese market
and he looks pretty good but she's the
real the real protagonist in the story
and she's great for the Western market
and she's a woman so it's all very
contemporary and etc so you see the
structure behind it is actually a
cultural change because now the values
of the West are being inserted in the
Chinese market with the Chinese co-opted
cooperating with them and as I believe
China's becoming more
capitalistic all the time partly through
the influence of movies the audience
wants to see individual people doing
what they want to do in life and going
out there and kicking ass and not being
under the thumb of some you know Emperor
or despot
so I think that this is why the whole
storytelling thing is so exciting
because it really is a universal
experience
you